hi everyone my name is Gabrielle creve
coeur I know that there's going to mix
up on the schedule like the board to
something else the app says another the
site says another so I think me and
Bobby got our talks mixed up I'm on the
board downstairs it says that he's
actually in this room and i'm in pepsi
encore so if you're here for Bobby he's
actually in Pepsi encore so if you leave
I won't feel bad now if you leave later
I want to be like dang I really have
that so if you're not sure what the
topic of today's discussion is today is
how to build your child their very own
frozen node but so this is a hardware
talk I know someone asks me earlier it's
just like a virtual bod chatbot because
there's all these bots nowadays you
really don't know what we're discussing
so this is a hardware talk so a little
bit about myself um I am a technical
evangelist at Microsoft I just completed
my first year last June so I'm
technically now a veteran and I should
know how to do my job you can follow me
on twitter at no way she codes and you
could actually follow my blog no way she
codes calm before Microsoft I was a
computer science major from the Florida
State University go noles so if you ever
one discussed college football we can do
this all day no uh-huh at Florida State
University I focused a lot on web dev
JavaScript basic HTML it wasn't standard
at my school but I just went above and
beyond to learn all things web did
because I wanted I thought it was just
pretty cool all my internships where web
dev develop was web dev development and
then once I got to my job I decided that
I want to do something different because
i was really bored with web did it's
still interesting to me but i feel like
it wasn't challenging me anymore so what
I went in to do was okay you know I
talked to my boss about it at the
Technical Evangelist we all kind of have
our own different focuses on my team so
we can reach out to everybody and kind
of hit different fields of people you
know actually there's no tech te on my
team that actually
net which is pretty funny because
everybody thinks got net and C sharp
with Microsoft but nobody on my team
actually does that so I kind of wanted a
way that was like you know what's new
what's happening what's going on in the
world and i discovered hardware and
javascript can actually go together and
it kind of blew my mind so as a CS
student though we didn't really do
anything hardware and it was really very
a such a great transition to learn about
circuits and electronics and things like
that so i wanted to make a talk for are
others that you know we're new to it and
even if this isn't new material even the
technologies that i'm using may be new
to you so I do want to know a little bit
about my crowd so I'm just going to
throw out little questions and if it
applies to you you know just raise your
hand so how many people in here are have
never done anything hardware before and
just feel like this is all new and
they're just interested in getting
started oh wow okay that's great how
many of you are kind of like me where
it's like well I don't think I'm a
beginner anymore but I'm still learning
a lot I'm not like totally 110% on
hardware but I do like it oh and how
many of you were just like I'm a beast
like I do this all day every day all
right great it's always good to know
your audience because it's like I don't
want to talk about the basics and
there's other people in the room like or
I already know this like can we move on
so thank you for that so let's just talk
about the story I mean as once you get
into professional career you know a lot
of people start families they have a lot
going on and it's kind of just like I
feel like there's a hard way to figure
out well now that I have a family or a
child of your life whether it be a
daughter a nice a goddaughter something
like that you know you always want to
give them time because kids are cute if
you don't think it's acute then I'm
sorry um because kids are cute and you
know you just you want to be able to
give him everything so this is the child
of my life she's not my daughter and you
know we look just like she's actually my
six-year-old sister so the gap is crazy
I don't know what my parents are doing
but that's on them
nothing but either way you know I treat
her kind of like a daughter cuz you're
six I'm like twenty-three so everywhere
I go with her it's just like you know I
want to give you the world but when I
graduated from college and I would go
home I'll go home and work from home
when he fix this sorry yes I would go
home and work from home you know we'd
actually like kind of fight it's weird
fighting with the safety rule because
she's so smart for six he thinks he says
it's believed unbelievable but it's just
like you don't you don't have tea
parties with me anymore and you don't
want to do this like you don't like me
and I'm just like no I have a job you
know this is it doesn't really register
with her so it was really actually
breaking my heart because she really is
my world and it's just like okay well I
need to find a way to make my work time
my play time so in my head I made my
system and my customer like what can I
make for you that'll make you want to be
like yeah I love this but I'm also
learning I'm building and you're my test
subject I can turn that in for work pet
sounds great so that is the story of how
this bot came to be before we actually
kind of get started into the building of
the node bod and things like that I do
want to talk about you know how do you
actually get started in hardware and how
do you figure out what you want and what
you want to do there are about a million
different one types of boards that you
want to get started with and when you
look up hardware or microcontrollers and
micro processors you know you'll have a
vast majority of options like it's just
crazy you don't really know where to
start as a beginner from my experiences
the first things that normally pop up or
the first two things that are like what
boy should i start with her all these
projects that people are building with
boards is usually in arduino and a
raspberry pi and they're so popular but
a lot of people don't always know the
difference so the difference in to me is
an Arduino is actually a microprocessor
so your Arduino is really good at taking
maybe one or two things and doing it
very well it is not it doesn't have its
own operating system you actually give
it
old via your computer you can actually
bluetooth code to it and then it just
does that one thing over and over and
over and over again for you it's really
great it does have digital input and
output pins and it works for simple
things versus when you have a Raspberry
Pi you have a mini computer in your
hands at all times anything that your
computer can do most likely your
Raspberry Pi can do so when you want
your eyes when you have a project where
it's like I to do this this that and the
next and process all of this and work
with that you might want to raspberry pi
so when you're thinking of you know well
what what do I need to get done and
you're thinking of your problem first
things first I would think of your
complexity think of how complex your
issue is and what you actually need from
it it is also kind of weird because a
lot of the things that arise a lot of
hands that Arduino can do a raspberry pi
can do but then it comes down to the
connections and how they Raspberry Pi
has a million-in-one different pins if
you never done have never done
electrical engineering you don't
understand pins and pin outs and how
this connects to this I would really
suggest in Arduino to start because
their pin outs are actually a bit more
simplified which is a Raspberry Pi pin
out every pin is actually every layer of
pin is actually something different and
you're not always going to know what
connects for what versus a Raspberry Pi
you can kind of plug I mean sorry versus
an Arduino you can kind of plug in
anything anywhere and just stayed a pin
number and it'll all work the same any
questions ok I feel free that stopped me
at any time while I'm talking if you
would like to know anything so another
thing that's really important to know is
ok now that I have my hardware you know
how do I want to actually make my board
work what do I want to get started with
so a lot of times these boards will have
native languages that they're used to
our dwie nose actually are really big
with they call them sketches they're
very they're very similar to c and c++
or like a mixture so usually if i write
in arduino sketch i will probably write
it in c++ and it normally works just
fine there's very
little airs a raspberry pi guess it is a
computer so honestly you can really run
anything on in any language that you
want however a lot of the tutorials a
lot of there's actually a terminal on
there everything that it's natively
running is Python so if you really good
with Python and you love that a
raspberry pi is the way to go that's
really good to know for me I love
JavaScript and you're like well nothing
he said and included JavaScript so how
does that make any sense well as I was
saying when I was looking up things from
my job I discovered JavaScript and
hardware and they called them node BOTS
so you're literally running nodejs on
your hardware how this is happening is
not me I'm not that great yet but one
day this guy his name is Rick Waldron
he's super cool he's located in New York
he has actually created a bot framework
called Johnny 5 so I'm just see if I
could pull up the website for you really
quick about computers a little slow okay
so this is literally Johnny far as you
see it's called the robotics and IOT
platform Johnny 5 is actually able to
work with a multitude of boards just
like the Raspberry Pi the Arduino
there's tehsils there's a million 01
things and actually has great
documentation on how to get started and
what you want to get done and etc etc
what it really does is it will use it
will actually do javascript to only
communicate with its base language so
when you're running JavaScript you're
really just controlling any C sharp
Barney C++ sorry that you might have
uploaded already on your Arduino and
I'll actually show you guys how that'll
work in a second so yeah if you ever
just want to know it's Johnny Five Donny
dash five dot IO hold on you guys this
is networking app okay so Oh Johnny five
dot IO it's a really great place to get
started like I said great documentation
and there are a bunch of people actually
if you find the gate number github
repository that's a bunch of people that
are actively building on this and adding
to it and things like that so it's a
great community to actually be a part of
and I'm glad it was one of my first ones
to be a part of in my job okay back to
the slides
so just like everything in the world
when it comes to programming and getting
started there's always that one program
that you learn when you first get
started with this hello world there is
actually a hello world in the hardware
world before we get there though i do
want to skip forward for a second just
so you understand something that i'm
actually going to show you so these are
shields hardware has a lot of
accessories and things you can add to
them so a shield is pretty much an
additional piece that you can add to
normally your arduino usually has
shields but a lot of other boards will
have it as well I don't think I've ever
seen a Raspberry Pi shield I could be
wrong but mostly when you look up
shields they use to go with in Arduino
and a shield will fit snugly right on
top of your Arduino and actually give it
the same pin out so you can still add
other pins to your Arduino but the
purpose of shields is because your base
hardware your regular um Arduino Uno
cannot do everything that your brain may
want it to do so for example if you want
to play music if you want to light up a
bunch of lights if you want to actually
connect to Wi-Fi your board are doing
the board can't do all those things by
themselves so there are numerous amount
of shields out there that may provide
different functionalities for the
different projects you may want so it's
really cool to just see what they have
out there and look into it and things
like that so I mentioned that because I
actually have a shield on my board right
now and I didn't want you guys to look
at the Arduino and the shield while I'm
doing hello world and you're just like
well that doesn't look in Arduino I
don't want to go into what my shoulders
yet but we will get there so first let
me show you how hello world works and
you're going to see on the C++ aspect of
your Arduino sketch and then how the
JavaScript works on top of that so with
Arduino to upload code is that big
enough everybody all right to upload
code it's it's literally this is your
your interface you don't have anything
else you can upload different sketches
you have a sketchbook there's already
built-in examples and things like that
when you're working with the Johnny Five
framework what they use is standard for
model so fremada is pretty much the
protocol that yard we know uses when
it's actually communicating with your
with your computer and things like that
so the communication between the board
and I think I know what's going on so
for model will be actually something you
always see when you're using your
Arduino you download from auto you get
it on your board it's pretty standard to
do everything else though you will not
need standard fremada but when you're
actually running Johnny Five you will so
it's just very simple you honestly get
fermata it comes built in with your
Arduino IDE you literally just go two
examples fine fermata and then go to
standard fremada and it will pop up
right here so it's also really important
to note which this will also come into
play later is you always want to know
what port your Arduino is coming in this
can always change as you can see on my
macbook oops let me to click it on my
macbook it looks like this like dense
see you USB modem but on a Windows
machine it actually will say like comic
com1 com2 cm3 so just in case you have a
Windows machine that you're working on
this it's like her port number didn't
look like my port number is something
wrong no just different machines so you
want to keep track of that right now 14
21 is my base number that's the only
thing that will change the rest of the
the porch string will say exactly the
same but your numbers was actually
really important so that's highlighted
i'm going to upload some standard for
mana on to it at the bottom you can see
i know it's really tiny I can't make
that big I'm sorry but it says uploading
and let you know that it's done so now
for the javascript part of it now that i
have standard from water on it i can do
anything that Johnny 5 is capable of
doing at this point so I'm just going to
open up my Johnny Five file so hello
world this is literally nine lines of
code that is going to make my LED blink
and normally with Johnny Five you're not
going to have
very extensive piece of JavaScript it's
really just going to be something this
small maybe a little bit bigger when
you're running Johnny 5 I mean we're in
the Johnny 5 framework it's pretty
simple it's pretty straightforward so as
you can see um is anybody not familiar
with Snowden or node modules okay so if
you don't know no Jas is pretty much
running JavaScript outside of the web
it's pretty cool right now my favorite
thing to do and so when you're running
it outside of the web node has absolute
more concern that better great node has
these things called modules coming from
an object-oriented background when I
think of what a module is I can almost
compare it to a class even though
unknown module is more of a package but
I'm right up there where it says
required Johnny 5 that is a node module
and it is in it contains a bunch of
different functions different objects
different variables that you can access
once you call your node module into your
code does that make sense is there any
other questions on that ok so as you see
at the top we're saying hey I just want
to bring in the node module Johnny 5 and
you just giving it a name so 5 so every
time that five is included in the code
we're just calling upon the node module
the next line you're creating a board
object which is only just grabbing a
definition of what a board is from your
Johnny Five module from then on you're
actually running your function okay well
when your board is on and when my board
is ready can you just run the function
that I'm telling it below is anybody
misunderstanding that or is there any
thing weird ok so under that as you can
see it says hey we have another object
called an LED and I want this led to be
instantiated as the LED object that that
Johnny 5 provides that definition of LED
that Johnny 5 provides and in between EC
has this number 13 that number 13 is
just the pin on the Arduino that you're
going to plug in your LED
too so when you're adding LEDs or you're
adding servos or additional parts to
yard we know they're most likely going
to be accessed via a pin so your PIN
number is very important depending on
what kind of bored you are using
sometimes your pin is not actually a
number sometimes it's like a 1 or D
something in this case for your Arduino
to just pin 13 so really quickly get
this led up and running where is so you
guys can actually see what's going on
oops can you guys see me hi so this is
my arduino shield on top the Arduino is
right at the bottom so the shields at
the top and literally these are the male
header pins which means it's just taking
something being plugged into it that's
all it's a male header pin that's also
taking and these these this pin out is
actually identical to what the pin out
is at the bottom on the actual Arduino
so that any pin you plug into the top
the Arduino can still process it so I'm
just going to plug in this led right
here to pin 13 and ground so ultimately
doing is completing a circuit pin 13 is
kind of giving the is like putting power
up into the LED and then the power is
being pushed down into ground and it's
like looping around so it's completing
your circuit yeah so now that the LED is
plugged in let's actually run the code
really quick I know my head is in the
way and then we're just going to say
node hello world
y'all see that yeah so as you noticed
you know we upload it oh go ahead class
yeah let me take me off this is awkward
now you know okay so as you can see
pretty much what we did was we were able
to yeah we uploaded the standard for
Mata on the standard protocol on to our
do we know but honestly the javascript
is what controlled whatever standard
fremada was giving it cuz Dana fermata
just is like hey your Arduino could do
these basic things in JavaScript was
like well I'm going to take these basic
things and make it happen does that make
sense to everyone it's pretty cool for
anybody that just wants to stay
JavaScript focus because you don't
actually have to look at the standard
for model code at all you don't have to
do c++ if you've never done it before so
if you just want to stay JavaScript
focus it is a great way to do that so
Johnny five people remember that so now
let's actually talk about my frozen bot
how we built in and what goes into it I
normally actually have a doll I think I
might have her actually okay I do have
her so this is Elsa everybody okay so
does anybody not know what frozen is
really quickly all right so if you don't
have a child in your life you might not
know what frozen is frozen is the
greatest movie of all time
whoa I say this because I really hated
it until my little sister was like no
you have to watch this movie with me
like this is happening they said there
was no this is not a discussion this is
like no I'm telling you like we're
watching this and it's actually a really
good kids movie so I pretty much made
this bot it's all an illusion what I do
is I normally take my Elsa doll and I
have I got it actually from the dollar
store it was actually a container that
had snowflakes on it cuz Elsa you know
snow she like blow snow around and
things like that was great she's really
cool and so I would put Elsa on top put
my arduino on the bottom and kind of
like stuff some stuffing in this she
doesn't see the board and then i would
actually let the board work so the way
it works is the frozen bodies
voice-activated so once i turn it on she
has to Elsa Elsa pass it here frozen
frozen Elsa or sing and when she hears
those words then she will sing snippets
of the infant else's song let it go if
you haven't heard let it go you will
hear today not the whole song not the
whole song it'll just be snippets of it
so that that's what I built for my
sister because honestly you know clearly
she was obsessed I honestly I think
christmas break one year we watched it
every day Christmas freakish three weeks
that is three weeks the frozen needless
to say I'm over it now but I actually
ended up falling in love with the movie
I actually have my own like stuffed
animal of Olaf if you know who Olaf is
he's my favorite character in the movie
and I like begged for my mom my mom to
buy it for me on blu-ray I was like no I
I need this movie like today so so it
was for her but I actually did find
enjoyment actually building building it
myself so first thing the hardware that
I decided to go with for this project
was an Arduino which you just saw that
shield on top of it and what that shield
is it's just an mp3 player shield
because you're wondering like well
where's music come from inside of the
shield there is an SD card and I simply
just put I think five snip
of the let it go song like the
highlights of the song that everybody
knows and I put it on there and once the
shield is triggered it'll play the music
so then on top of that what makes the
shield even more awesome is I didn't
have to wire up a microphone I didn't
have to wire up a speaker to it the
shield actually has a mic port and a
speaker port look at that it's all done
for me you know I mean because if you
look up my arduino and a microphone
it'll give you a give you a way to wire
one up a microphone which is really that
great but this just made it so much eat
like just plug this in and it does
everything i wanted to do wow great so
that was honestly what I used and as I
explained to you before there were
standard for model library but with this
shield it actually came with this own
library one and two at the moment Johnny
Five wasn't compatible with it so now
I'm sitting here like I guess this isn't
a no bot anymore you know we're just
gonna let this go I'm gonna go get it
guys I didn't do that on purpose I
didn't do that on purpose i swear but um
so what i actually found is there is
actually another javascript to board
Frank or node module or framework it's
not as popular but a lot of people do
use it for things that Johnny Five work
it was not compatible for at the time
because it has grown since I build this
project but even still some people just
prefer this method so it is a node
module called serial port which really
just communicates the Arduino via serial
port oh look at that make sense Boop so
it was it was actually pretty simple so
all they are doing a library I needed at
that point then was just a sketch to
make the shield do what I wanted to do
and my JavaScript at that point kinda
was the brains behind everything and
kind of just shot signals and grabbed
info from the shield so my javascript
actually does all the work it's okay
which actually makes me like syrup or
even more because I feel like I actually
see my JavaScript do all the work and on
top of that actually have this little
mini speaker I know it's like bright I
used to have this one that was a pompom
so it blended more and it was blue so
it's sat under the blue container just
just right but it just it just kept
blowing on me and that would've been
awkward so I have this little speaker
that's nice and bright you guys can't
miss it I'm just going to go over so
code with you really quick so you can
understand so like I said with my
JavaScript doing all the work being the
brains behind everything so all my
javascript is doing right here is we
have at the top a record module to know
that we are actually recording something
by default right now I honestly this
this particular bot actually just
records for my computer because you
can't give you can't really have a
Arduino run by itself unless you give it
power somewhere else so you have the
Bluetooth added to it so it can man so
the Bluetooth can actually upload this
get it can get kind of get kind of
complicated I'm actually rebuilding this
board on a more portable board so then I
don't have to talk to my computer and it
looks better but to her she doesn't
notice these things because it's like
the but the hardware isn't really going
anywhere you know she's just going to
take the doll and run around which is
fine so that is what the top module does
it's really just for recording purposes
the next module and it's FS standard
filestream so it's what is going to
write my recording into a binary file
and then under that is speech de ESO
speech dance is actually a module I made
making a module is very easy it's just
like making a class unless honestly just
how you call it my speech is file and
that's kind of how the speech is
actually interpreted in things like that
in the speech is where I called the API
that will tell me if she said the words
that I'm looking for so the API I used
is actually Microsoft cognitive services
I honestly not being biased I did do
microsoft office services and I did do
google voice and google voice kept
giving me arm sixty percent sure that
instead of saying Elsa you said le or
instead of saying frozen you said frost
and I'm just like
isn't going to work but Microsoft
Congress service is actually very
accurate and I hate to say this but I
was really surprised because you know I
do love my company but you know
sometimes we not always on point but we
were on point with this one because I
was like yeah great don't tell them I
said that so these are just variables
that are needed to make that API work I
just have my client ID my client secret
the file name that'll be used to push
that will be used to make my recording
into a file and then this number so this
number this random number is know how I
said that I had five snippets on the on
the shield it's because I don't want it
to play the same thing over and over I
just want to play something so it'll
pick a random number one through five
and all these variables are going to be
passed to the function that actually
talks to the shield are there any
questions so far okay great so in this
function right here if this is just
really where the recording starts
actually recording stuff recording and
doing anything voice app voice related
can be a little complicated and node
because node runs asynchronously so
it'll be like hey record start but
actually go to the bottom now and do
something else at the same time and your
other function may be like well I didn't
get my recording it so you actually want
to play around a lot with no to figure
out how you can fake the synchronous
nature of it so I did a set timeout
function which makes it like not do
anything else until this recording is
done there are other ways around the
asynchronous nature of node there are
actually known modules like a sink that
makes it run synchronously I'm not going
to go too deep in that but that is
actually very very important when you're
dealing with known box if you want
things to go in order it won't it'll all
happen at the same time so you actually
want to find a way to make it go in the
order that true blood so office is
really saying is start recording once it
here's something I gave it like maybe 10
seconds and my sister actually that's
four seconds up there but my sister is
not going to take longer than 10 seconds
to be like okay I want to stall the
saying like you know she's pretty smart
she knows
she wants she's going to get right to it
she wants to freakin dog thing so so I
give about for second second snippet and
once it takes this snippet it pipes it
down into a WAV file and it sends the
WAV file into the speech fun function so
the speech fun is what actually calls
that speech jas module I was talking
about and it runs the API get and post
request that i actually created in the
speech in this bjs file so that is all
that happens down here this is what is
this I think it's going to make it
happen by on purpose and I don't want
that okay no that's fine actually I was
a test statement so down here this is
the analysis function so once i give it
up to the once i give it up to the API
microsoft microsoft coughlin services
will return there's a speech-to-text
method for me and there will turn
everything that she had said text into a
good JSON and I pretty much go through
the text in the JSON and I look for did
she say Elsa frozen or sing and if she
does then weird says port don't start it
starts the serial port with the random
number so you just pass in to the serial
port hey here's my number play the song
any questions anybody want to see it
though
yes yes I think though we're serious oh
the purpose of the random number is
because all right I have five tracks on
here and I don't want to play the same
track every time and the way that the
shield will play a track as we'd give it
a number you gave you give it to you
give it for you give it whatever it'll
play that track that's located on the SD
card so it's just a random number so
that every time the doll was saying the
same part of shoes it's like this is
boring because she gets bored really
easily so anybody want to see it work
yes all right so you don't actually see
the doll and the aesthetics of it all
but when I put it together I swear it's
really nice so I just want to make sure
that my port number is correct this is
the serial port function i was telling
you about and that port number is
actually very important because then
they won't know where to communicate
this right here is what we call a serial
port object it's pretty much sending in
the the native variables osa variables
but the native settings that the Arduino
has if I was running the shield be
Arduino the stereo port just passing
that to it so it knows how to configure
the Arduino that's all that is and then
right here is that start function and I
was discussing and pretty much this SP
right is what will give it the number
and make it play make sense so let's
make this bad boy go
something isn't right not this dog
should
so this is super tiny so node oops
anybody want to come try it do you
remember the keywords frozen so yeah
just come up all you could to stay right
there so I talked to the computer anyway
so when I say go you might want to say
Elsa bunch of times frozen you could say
a sentence about three words in it and
we'll see what happens okay ready go
Elsa Sydney frozen sing Elsa up uh oh
this got awkward uh-huh I haven't had
this up before clearly my subscription
key just died this morning this
obviously will be in to second fix
people oh no I think it's because
honestly i chant try to I tried to like
do my environmental variables and I
think that's what's happening so I'm
hoping that that's all that it is
hopefully it's nothing else cuz it was
stuff if it is you know all right
try it again jiri yeah all right Elsa
singing frozen Elsa Elsa okay
no you don't always something and just
gonna win oh oh sorry guys I did skip a
step I still had to stand ramada on it
and as I told you guys before it has to
have the actual shield one so I'm just
going to quickly re upload this just
know everybody makes mistakes we're not
all perfect I wish I was perfect though
so this is just pretty much the same
thing Oh another sketch but as you can
see that you know they're pretty simple
just upload it's uploading down here
speakers on everything's all good to go
great now I promise you this time is
social work okay come on you ready you
you thank you for being a trooper with
me all right let's do it Elsa Allison
frozen Elsa okay thinking about it
that's good that's a good sign
so they're like 10 seconds so like it
just ended because the clapping was
about you know that much time yeah you
can go thank you so much um thank you
for her she was awesome guys she's a
trooper um but pretty much this is it
actually talking to the seer talking to
the board it'll have a lot usually it
has a lot of more numbers and just
letting you know that it's working but
what I actually noticed when I was
working with serial port is it would go
through an infinite loop and just play
over and over and over and over again I
was like no so if you look actually
right here in the serial port after it
actually runs the function after it like
gives it the number it close as a serial
port very quickly so that's why it looks
like oh the data is being cut off no the
data will keep going trust me so that's
all that is um so let's get back to the
slides
so we actually discussed all of this all
right so next steps if you would like to
build your own frozen bot you can do
that I have step-by-step instructions I
have a list of all the devices that all
of the things are going to need for your
device and things like that I akkad that
ms / frozen but i'll actually show you
the site right after this it'll have all
the same pictures you've seen so you'll
know it's the right one because these
are these are self photographs because
you know I had to like add my personal
touch so that's my Olaf doll isn't he so
cute um and then it's like you know just
because I built this bot doesn't mean
you can't take it to the next step you
know add things to it you don't make
your bot spin around and do a little
dance or something I don't know but also
you if your child doesn't like frozen
you can totally supplement this for a
whole different character I personally
like mulan she's freaking awesome so
like if I could easily takes meters from
the movie upload that to the SD card
changes the doll and the aesthetics of
it all and I'll have moolah bot you know
so this this bot isn't necessarily set
in stone and I hope this session has
taught you that you know you can kind of
take this play around with it have some
fun with it and things like that
definitely look into Johnny Five if you
want to get into node box if you just
want to do hardware in general there are
a million in one tutorials all over the
place and at this point there are a
million in different one platforms to
run your board I use my native platforms
but once again there is Windows IOT it's
getting there it's good it's good for
what it can do but it might be limited
in the things that you may want to do so
feel free to explore all the different
options you have for each board because
there are a million and one ways to
implement things nowadays so that's the
end of my talk if you have any questions
if you have critiques if you want to
tell me that I suck you can come and do
that please let me know that I suck so I
can get better but I hope you guys
really enjoyed this time in this talk
and I hope you guys are all able to take
away something from this thank you
you